two years of brexit negotiations begin
this morning Britain's Prime Minister is
about to officially trigger her
country's withdrawal from the European
Union under Article 50 of the EU
Constitution here is a live look at the
House of Commons where Theresa May is
taking questions from lawmakers we're
delivering her statement on brexit
Jonathan Vigliotti is outside the houses
of parliament Jonathan good morning good
morning triggering article 50 is really
just a nice way of saying filing for
divorce and just like any split leaving
the EU won't be pretty the sun has risen
on a breakup many in the UK and
throughout europe hoped wouldn't happen
but later in brussels where the european
union is headquartered the divorce
papers will be filed Prime Minister
Theresa May signed the official letter
Tuesday in a statement she said it is my
fierce determination to get the right
deal for every single person in this
country later saying that includes EU
nationals who have quote made this
country their home the countdown is on
the dead British news is already
counting down the 730 days to the
separation right to the second this
two-year divorce process could require
Britain to borrow as much as 73 billion
dollars on the line the UK's
international trading relationships and
free passage to the 27 other member
nations negotiating between countries
will be as complicated and historic as
it sounds what is for certain is that
we're getting back control of our
country and in future will they get
things right or get things wrong we will
be in charge the referendum to leave the
EU or brexit was just narrowly passed
last summer and some who voted to leave
said they were tricked by politicians
who oversold non-existent health care
benefits and promised to stop
immigration Prime Minister may has
already found a helping hand in the
process from President Trump who told
her the brexit would be wonderful the
English a splinter in the middle piece
of me has divided the entire firmament
of these Island or message is not fatal
if it's Donald Trump and two nations may
not be enough and the EU certainly
hoping the UK feels the pain gale to
send a clear
message to other member nations who may
be thinking about leaving Thank You
Jonathan Vigliotti reporting from London